a shoreline that bristles with the
rusting Hallmarks of War kinman Island
lined with defensive spikes
it's carried the threat of an attack
from China for decades and it's Weighing
on them once again
China has been Crossing into the skies
and Waters around here known as the
Taiwan Strait on an almost daily basis
in August it carried out its largest
ever military exercises around Taiwan
raising tensions to the highest level in
years
a former Soldier is worried about a
return to the dark days
in the 1980s he lived in these tunnels
designed to hide ships and supplies
he thinks it's Taiwan that needs to cool
down its rhetoric we are the Italian
foreign
but Taiwan is on guard aggravated by
Chinese drones they view them as
psychological warfare and they've
already shot a civilian one down
[Music]
but you won't see anyone fleeing here in
fact tourists flock here
before the pandemic many of them Chinese
[Music]
customers of what feels like a conflict
curiosity shop
[Music]
across the island there's even a
propaganda wall
a so-called Sonic weapon
now laptop by selfie lovers
if China really want to get Taiwan it's
easy
but he cannot get our people our hearts
our Spirits we don't want to become a
part of China
but China is only two kilometers away
and many people love to shop there
we have very close ties with China in
many aspects such as tourism and some
commercial activities I don't think we
we live in front line in human
this isn't a place where the bunker
mentality primed for conflict far from
it the Cold War thawed here years ago
and many people see the benefits of
living so close to China now but they
also know that their neighbor is
ambitious determined and deeply
unpredictable
a full-scale invasion is hugely risky
for Beijing but piling on the pressure
seems to be a top priority Cordelia
Lynch Sky News kinman Taiwan